do you remember the whole point of doing
vectors right introducing this idea of
vectors is to think about lengths and
also to think about complex numbers
detached as it were from the origin not
only just thinking about this is our
important point this is our important
point right I can take the position
vector which is off of the origin and I
can just move him wherever I like and
that'll be a free vector but it's still
equivalent ok so here's a little
subheading you can make shifting the
point of reference we're gonna have a
look at a couple of principles for what
happens when you try and think about
arguments and moduli that are not just
measured from the origin okay so before
we get into any of that I want you to
consider this very pedestrian looking
statement ok the absolute value of 5
minus 2 is the absolute value of 3 ok
now this doesn't look like it's saying
anything profound we're just crunching
numbers like 5 take awaits you
he's 3 ok but this is actually saying
something different for instance
remember that the answer you value
something the modulus or something just
means how far are you from the origin or
rather how far is that from the origin
ok so what this right-hand side of the
equation is saying is what is the
distance from 3 to the origin okay
that's what the right hand side is
saying now the left hand side is equal
to that because the values are the same
but the left hand side is saying
something quite different right it's not
saying what's the distance or three zero
there's no three or zero at all in there
right what is there five and two that's
the distance that this is talking about
right the left hand side is the distance
from five to two okay
now this happens to also be the distance
from two to five and the distance from
negative 3 to the origin and so on but
just
because things are equal in value does
not mean they are saying the same thing
okay so let's consider now what about to
pick sample five let's consider this guy
we need a diagram and just for the sake
of consistency let's all do it something
like this
excuse me
now here's a challenge for you right if
you've turned your Argand diagram what
roughly like what mine looks like okay
you have a scale or anything like that
and we're gonna be numbers on here but
we can still work out
where's n minus dead what is based on
where's Enid what are and then we we can
work out a distance okay so let's think
about this a subtraction is the same as
adding the negation remember that so if
I want to think about ways that minus n1
is I first whatever way it might as said
one is can't think about that
excuse me so if that's where the f1 is
where does - does everyone go it's um
it's rotated pi radians around the
origin so now I'm here roughly speaking
that's where negatives ever wanted ok
now I want to think about this is the
position vector well let's take the free
vector move it up to here because adding
Zen and negatives at one is the same as
stringing together those vectors are you
sick of me saying this yeah I'm just
gonna keep saying it's like it's drummed
into your head I'm gonna do that and
then I'm gonna string onto that
negatives everyone ok so that means I've
gone somewhere maybe hear that victim in
ok I'm going that direction right
because I'm adding negatives at 100 and
maybe say one goes that direction
so the vector has to go into that ok so
that's where I'm going
so this point here is Z takeaway said
what don't care about pop him in another
color
so that is said takeaway said one then
the modulus have said take aways at one
is the distance from the origin up to
that point right but that's not the only
thing it's equal to right we've been
looking at these parallelograms I heard
of her and her again right you see this
a parallelogram there in the first
quadrant right it's equal to the color
this said minus n1 bat modulus clearly
is equal to this do you see that you see
my parallelogram right
so if this is also said take away the
zip one right I've now got two different
definitions two different geometric
definitions for what Zed takeaways in
one is right for starters my 3 1 this is
the distance I'm now thinking like I was
thinking up here right it's the distance
from zero isn't one as a complex number
as a point to where to the origin right
but my blue one was here right it's also
the distance from Z to Z one I have a
new point of reference right I'm no
longer thinking about the origin anymore
that's what thinking about three vectors
allows me to do I can move over here and
I'm not measuring from there anymore I'm
measuring from over here it's just as
much the distance from Z to Z ok now
mark that like that because really this
is actually saying the same thing did
you notice five take away to this five
take away and choose your frame of
reference that's your new starting point
where you're measuring for all three
also has its point of reference in there
it's just we don't write it it's minus
zero you see that so that's why I'm
measuring from the origin it's sort of
hidden away in there we just don't
Atticus you take away zero the number
doesn't change right but in the same way
I'm going from zen minus f1 minus zero
over there or I'm changing my point of
reference to save one okay so now I can
think about for instance hmm what if I
asked for you to sell me the locus of
points such as the module serves that -
a member - does that mean that means
remember they're like using my notation
here is that a variable instead one's
like an actual spot that I've picked
with actual coordinates that can move
Zed can move anywhere so long as the
distance from zero to this point is -
does that make sense we did this
question just a minute ago except we did
it for the origin but now I have a new
point of reference I said what is my new
point of reference right so I mean my
diagram is no scale in it but I could do
something one is you see what I've got
so the distance from Zed like all of
these points on my own we had some
really bad cycle all of the points on
the circle I can here here here and the
distance from Zed to that new point of
reference should be two because it's a
circle because I've got the radius there
okay so if I give you this it's really
different kind of this but I've shifted
where I'm where I'm starting to measure
from does that make sense
okay mmm it's a great question so if I
gave you this right
I've got Zen takeaway a complex number
you just watch out right watch out
because what's the complex number that
I'm subtracting in fact it's not - no -
I it's actually 1 plus I right there is
the one that's my actual center equals 2
so 1 plus you know something like that
that's my actual sense that would be
provided - okay okay now let's think
about arguments that was on okay the
answer is probably both to be sure they
know what I'm doing and then as I get
more confident I will do up towards I
would lean towards geometrically because
it's faster I don't have to do as much
working but I'll show you how to do it G
um algebraically it's not hard like you
just had the crepes through some lights
okay in fact maybe okay you know how to
calculate what does right you now need
to think back in terms of the distance
from zero said one as a point Zen - said
one is a whole point on this time versus
Z there won't be two separate points
okay so therefore to get what this thing
is I need to know there's an X plus iy
and then there's this minus one plus I
that's sort of messed up in there right
so here's the word righteous I'd say
this is X plus iy minus y equals two
what's the real component in here X
minus one very good let's just highlight
that X and negative ones they're real
right and while I'm at it you can see
the imaginary parts as well right
there's a menu bar there's imagine pot
so let's factorize it to make that clear
I've got let's see
X take away one all right you okay with
that they can't hold on a second now
that I've got this tighten up as a
single complex number to work out the
modulus it's just the square root of the
real spot squared plus the imaginary
part squared right Oh about a second
that's just the familiar old circle that
we've seen so many times before with a
center that one one of course it's a
center at one one because remember this
point is one of the real and one on the
imaginary one one you see where it is so
you can see you can crunch through the
algebra but it's much better than no way
of going oh yeah
I look at this and immediately I think
circle because I mean I've got a
constant radius right so that's how I
know it's a circle